e
[Música]
o dia a todos
e dizem que o mundo vai acabar mas não é
hoje não é hoje e não vai ser nos
próximos tempos porque a humanidade tem
mostrado que consegue vencer esses
vencer esses desafios
desafios estamos a data de hoje por
todos nós a viver
EA Superar esta esta pandemia Cruz
afetam a todos que nos afetou a
globalmente em todos os setores e
demonstramos que em
conjunto focados com objetivos Concretos
e com um caminho definido conseguimos
vencer as coisas mais difíceis das
coisas mais
prejudiciais para a nossa sobrevivência
e nos con é com esta com esta com este
foco
conseguimos o tamanho revermos nossas
situações
e em problemas que a data de hoje
nos conhecemos e que há bem ou mal todos
nós estamos focados em resolvê-los
falo-vos da nossa dependência
a enorme
uma tendência crónica de todos nós de
todos os todo o planeta toda a
humanidade que é a dependência dos
combustíveis hidrocarbonicos povos dos
combustíveis fósseis do problema
ambiental que criou a sua volta de um
problema que a data de hoje tempo
soluções para resolver temos
meios e precisamos de vontade vontade de
Todos precisamos de descobrir
caminhos para
motivar toda a gente sair nesse sentido
e e
a partir daí resolvemos o problema e
seguirmos em frente
porque aí a sua o caminho é isso que a
humanidade aprendeu a fazer a nos seus
vastos anos de existência
e nós enquanto enquanto
cidadãos Eu falo enquanto Engenheiros
tantos temos soluções que a data dos
podemos aplicar no imediato para
podermos fazer algo cada um de nós pode
fazer algo já não precisamos estar a
esperavam preparar uma tecnologia
que vai resolver o problema e tudo vai
ficar livre de carbono não está ao
alcance de todos nós estão ao alcance
de nossas casas podemos mudar as nossas
atitudes podemos
por Paris mudando o tipo de iluminação
mudamos nossos hábitos
mudando a forma como fazemos as nossas
coisas do dia-a-dia como os movimentos
e podemos escolher essas escolhas a data
de hoje estão a começar a estar a cidade
algumas delas bastante
bastante possíveis falo-vos do exemplo
da nossa mobilidade que é o que me traz
aqui numa uma forma mais focada portanto
e como sabemos os todos nós andamos a
gasolina andamos a gasóleo a temos os
nossos carros nossos mais já começa a
ver pessoas que adotaram outras outros
outras metodologias com os veículos
elétricos com a própria bicicleta que
funciona para os seus propósitos é uma
trotinete
agora podemos prescindir de uma vez por
todas do nosso automóvel se calhar não
se calhar em algumas fases nós podemos
fazer isso mas
não sei quantos de vós já são pais mas
quando chega aquela parte de ter que
levar a cadeirinha levar o saco das
Fraldas não vamos trotinete
garantidamente portanto são hábitos que
é difícil soltar nos deles é difícil
arranjar vamos uma alternativa simples e
direta mas existem alternativas e dos
exemplo da tecnologia que com orgulho
digo que foi desenvolvido em Portugal
que nos faz O que é que nos faz ter uma
possibilidade no imediato de instalar
dispositivos instalar sistemas que
permitem transformar os nossos veículos
os nossos carros do dia a dia em
veículos mais eficientes com menos
consumo com menos emissões isto sem ter
que trocar de carro e sem ter que trocar
a lógica e a nossa operacionalidade do
dia a dia continuamos usar combustíveis
continuamos a usar os nossos meios
habituais para nos movimentarmos mas
temos um motor mais eficiente estão até
que hoje que existe que os desafios
todos para
orar e lembrem-se é português esta mesma
tecnologia
e pode ser aplicada a tudo pode ser
aplicada
e há os motores industriais geradores de
caminhões pode ser aplicado na indústria
inclusiva onde temos o prazer já ter
praticamente 60 sistemas instalados ao
longo do mundo e em Portugal também
e com resultados enviados com resultados
que nos podem planos orgulhar dizer não
foi um custo para os nossos clientes
instalar em esses dispositivos Foi sim
uma mais-valia para todos porque eles
pouparam um ambiente pouco e movimentos
estão a melhorar EA dar continuidade a
uma transição que não pode ser enviada
nós não podemos todos de um ambiente
para outro deixar de andar de carro vou
deixar e mudarmos todos para veículos
elétricos que não seria compostável a
própria técnica não não permiti que isso
acontecesse Porque toda a rede elétrica
tem que ser alterada a todo todos os a
nossa maneira de pensar tem que ser e
nem tudo é aplicado a uma mobilidade
elétrica pesem por exemplo no veículo de
transporte de mercadorias que passa 24
sobre 24 horas a rolar não é possível
tenta eu tenho parar para carregar e
faça isto existem muitas possibilidades
que estão em cima da mesa onde nós
também estamos focados fria de criar as
soluções falsos por exemplo da
utilização de hidrogênio para como forma
de energia como forma de movimentar e de
forma depois de impulsionar a nossa
mobilidade
isso é algo que que
a data dos Tecnicamente possível mas é
algo que não vai acontecer do dia para o
outro não vai por quê Porque eu adoro
duas posso querer dizer eu vou comprar
um carro a hidrogênio um ir alho e um
gaio o que for já existe no mercado
podemos chegar um instante comprar os
onde é que eu vou abastecer tanto existe
todo um todo um caminho a fazer toda uma
preparação a fazer para conseguirmos
fazer esta transição energética esta é e
não dependência do do carbono e
passarmos por uma tecnologia mais limpa
sem por cento renovável a frente agora
aqui um pequeno uma pequena curiosidade
na prática tudo é renovável a grande
demora um bocadinho a mais tempo a ser
renovado os combustíveis a data de hoje
demoraram foi milhares de anos a serem
informados para que nós possamos
utilizar o que acontece é que nós
estamos a construir os mais depressa do
que aquilo que eles conseguem gerar
regenerar e voltar a sua forma original
por tentar procurar energias mais limpas
e energias mais
rapidamente renováveis com o meu exemplo
de hidrogênio o hidrogênio está em todo
lado o hidrogênio está nos próprios
combustíveis que nós utilizamos
adaptadores o hidrogênio está no ar que
respiramos e forma de água está presente
em todo o lado o que acontece é que nós
é utilizado com
alguma facilidade a tecnologia já vou
dormir em transformar ao diretamente da
água por exemplo de electrólise e
utilizá-lo como forma de armazenamento
de energia que que significa significa
que eu posso ter o meu veículo elétrico
que a propulsão sente o motor faz mover
as rodas e efetivamente elétrico mas o
armazenamento de energia está está sobre
a forma química sobre a forma de
hidrogênio esse hidrogênio ao ser
recombinado e ao gerar energia elétrica
no motor que se chama foi ao céu vai
permitir a um motor mover-se tal e qual
como o carro elétrico se move
adaptadores vantagens grande vantagem no
abastecimento eu não preciso deixar o
meu veículo carregar durante oito horas
da noite portanto eu posso manter a
minha mobilidade não ter a minha é o meu
movimento com uma pequena paragem como
um dos para abastecer os nossos carros e
em cinco minutos 10 minutos faço o texto
do meu veículo e sigo a minha viagem com
uma grande vantagem esse hidrogênio ao
ser utilizado ao ser convertido de novo
a energia elétrica a aos Inconfidentes
elétrica vai ver combinar-se com o
oxigênio existente no ar e vai ter uma
única emissão que água h2oh isto faz com
que o ciclo de regeneração desta mesma
energia seja muito curto e seja
facilmente controlável se temos de
esperar milhares de anos que a terra
Faça o seu trabalho
em paralelo se conseguimos utilizar para
a formação para a criação deste
hidrogênio energias limpas e energias
renováveis como solar como eu o Lico
podemos chamar este hidrogênio verde o
que significa que o processo de
transformação
E desde a água ou hidrogênio é feito
energia elétrica sim mas é um menos
elétrica que não tem qualquer tipo de
contaminantes para nosso cliente e ao
mesmo tempo estamos a conseguir saltar
por cima de um problema que a data de
hoje
existe nós sabemos temos consciência
dele que é o problema das Baterias todos
os veículos elétricos daqui a data de
hoje nós utilizamos sua em baterias E
essas baterias mais receba mais tarde
vão ter que ser
reciclados vão ter que ser transformadas
por quê que elas próprias são vão chamar
ele no queria dizer o único mas se
calhar o maior pela lente do veículo
elétrico mas que é um poluente que vai
contaminar o nosso mundo contaminar o
planeta não na nossa fase de utilização
mas na fase de produção e na fase de fim
de vida dos produtos Isto é sem dúvida
um caminho é um caminho que eu desafio a
todos que estudar desafios a todos
aplicar em e verificar em que a data de
hoje é claro que não estou a dizer vamos
todos filhos aqui vamos todos compraram
o veículo a hidrogênio e isso não será
possível a batata doce mas é um caminho
onde poderão a data de hoje já melhorar
o que tem com custos reduzidos tanto com
equipamentos dos que falo a
desenvolvido é um eu é um equipamento
custa sorveterias depósitos combustível
perfeitamente acessível a toda a gente
mas já vamos gastar o combustível
qualquer forma e ele vai vai vai durar
mais tempo após a sua instalação
portanto
Esse é o meu desafio é deixo-vos aqui o
limão uma mensagem de esperança uma
mensagem de
de
não está tudo perdido bastante
virtualmente não vamos passar a emissões
zero se calhar nos prazos que se
adicionam as gravamos demorar mais tempo
mas tem que ser uma mudança sustentável
uma mudança equilibrava em que cada um
de nós consiga fazer o seu papel e cada
um de nós consiga a
de dar o seu contributo para esta
mudança para esta alta a presta
alteração na forma de
gerir mos a nos nossos consumos
energéticos portanto era esta a mensagem
que eles tinham para para passar
sei quinta provavelmente Existe alguma
questão
bom
obrigada tá
E aí
[Música]